I don't know if you're following what's
going on in Hollywood right now but it's
in total shambles right now May 2nd the
writers go on a strike we're not going
to be writing anymore because of AI
residual protection what's going to
happen to us you guys are using AI to
get right scripts 11 500 Writers Guild
not writing anymore so guess what
Stephen Colbert go look at his YouTube
channel last time they did a video new
two months ago Jimmy Fallon Jimmy Kimmel
two months ago Jimmy Fallon is doing the
best stuff they're not even putting up
any content then July 14 Guess Who joins
them sag 160
000 members from sag join the strike so
now this whole thing is going on no
one's getting paid if you're part of seg
you kind of need to be part of Sac Union
to be protected but the bad thing about
being part of Sac you can't take another
job right now because you're part of the
Union so you have to either step away
from it that's 171 500 members no movies
no streaming no shows nothing then this
week Bob Iger on a CNBC interview shares
what he thinks this is disappointing
what's going on you got to see that
interview and then Ron Perlman from
Hellboy from from the 1987 Beauty and
the Beast he played the Beast and from
Sons of Anarchy you recognize the face
he gets angry he gets pissed off calling
out the man who made 27 million dollars
and everybody's like who's this 27
million dollar your person when you
Google Bob iger's salary 2022 27 million
dollars we're gonna follow this story
and we're going to talk about what the
solution is is it the big company's
fault are the writers not position
themselves well what should they be
doing moving forward we're going to talk
about that today
foreign
if you get value out of the video give
it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel but let's get right into it by
the way when you think about these
things like when's the last time both
writer's Guild and sag went on a strike
this should probably happen every year
right maybe every five years every 10
years what if I told you the last time
this happened was 1960s when they both
came together saying what is this all
about back then actors and writers
joined together to fight for fairness in
regards to residual payments from films
sold to television networks it's just
kind of fair hey I want to get paid
better I want to get paid fair with the
residuals told to get it that's a big
part of Hollywood we get it but the next
time this happens was 1980s and 1980s
was only actors going on a strike not
writers but then in 2007 2008 when
writers went on a strike this was again
for residuals from streaming services
you know the whole thing with Netflix
all these other things that was taking
place they went on a strike and that
cost just the city of Los Angeles an
estimated one and a half billion dollars
not actors just writers so the the
concept of both of these guys now as of
July 14 going on a strike this has not
happened since 19 1960s it's so
frustrating for these guys that I want
to give you context before I play these
clips this is Ron Perlman they're upset
about the fact that the executives are
making a lot of money I'll show you some
of the numbers here if you want to take
a look at this David zaslav from Warner
Brothers the last five years has made
498 million dollars re manual 346
million dollars read Hastings from
Netflix 209 million dollars Bob I grew
195 million dollars Ted from Netflix 192
million dollars you see the rest of the
names Rupert Murdoch Lachlan Murdoch
Brian Roberts all of these guys in the
last five years have made over 143
million dollars you guys are saying if
these guys are getting paid this kind of
money how about us and by the way even
the actors you know it's not fair Tom
Cruise last year in 2022 made 100
million dollars highest paid actor when
he did to the movie Top Gun how about
Will Smith he made 35 million dollars
Leo did 30 million dollars Brad Pitt the
30 million dollars Dwayne Johnson 22 and
a half Will Ferrell Hemsworth Vin Diesel
Tom Hardy Joaquin Phoenix Ryan Reynolds
Denzel all of them to 20 million dollars
how about us and by the way Ron Perlman
his net worth he's a millionaire he's
worth around 8 tell million According to
some of the data out there but watch
what he says when he calls out the 27
million dollar man and then I want to
let you hear from Bob Iger then I got a
couple thoughts here here's Ron Perlman
the mother
who said we're going to keep this thing
going until people start losing their
houses in their Apartments
listen to me
there's a lot of ways to lose your house
some of it is financial some of it is
karma
and some of it is just figuring out who
the said that and we know who said
that
and where he lives
there's a lot of ways to lose your house
you wish that on people
you wish that families starve while
you're making 27 million dollars
a year for creating nothing
be careful be really careful because
that's kind of
Disturbed up so everybody's like who's
this 27 million dollar man again I
showed you online if you look at how
much money he made Bob Iger in 2022 is
27 million dollars so it's a direct call
out here's what Bob Iger said on
defending him their position against
Union here's what he had to say well I
think it's very disturbing to me I you
know we've talked about uh disruptive
forces on this business and all the
challenges that we're facing and the
recovery from covid which is ongoing
it's not completely back this is the
worst time in the world to add to that
disruption there's a level of
expectation that they have that is just
not realistic and they are adding to a
set of challenges that this business is
already facing that is quite frankly
very disruptive they're not being
realisticated I know they're not why not
I can't I can't I can't answer that
question I again I respect their right
and their desire to get as much as they
possibly can in compensation for their
people like and I completely respect
that I've been around long enough to
understand that Dynamic and to
appreciate it but you also have to be
realistic about it with a business
environment and what this business can
deliver what do you do in the interim
a lot of scripts it will have a it will
have a very very damaging effect on the
whole business and unfortunately there's
huge collateral damage in the industry
to people who are you know who are
Support Services I could go on and on it
will affect the economy of you know
different regions even because there's
the size sheer size of the business now
you may say well I agree with Perlman
that's not cool that's not fair or you
may say I don't know Union always breaks
stuff they always get in there and hold
people hostage union doesn't typically
do good things they start off as good
eventually they hurt the people that
they wanted to help the whole point
right now is who needs who more and
who's going to Cave first are they going
to wait till people can no longer make
their mortgage payments then they're
going to come back and say hey sag we're
not with it I got to start making money
this is not cool this happens in
baseball when there's Collective
bargaining agreements and there's a
strike it happens in basketball it
happens everywhere but the recent point
in the fear of AI and the direction
they're going there was a movie that was
unflashed I took my kids to watch Flash
there's a scene at the end of the movie
which they're kind of using AI to
replicate actors likeness without Fair
compensations the flash it raised
eyebrows as it used these deep fake CGI
and depicting these deceased actors
steering up discussions of future
filmmaking so let me get this straight
so you can literally scan my body and
have me turned around in every possible
way put it in the system the system can
use me to use future trolls in a movie
and I shouldn't get paid for that that's
actually a valid argument to have so let
me get this straight I understand you
don't want me to do the work you're
going to use AI maybe I don't get paid
100 because I'm not actually there you
use in mind maybe it's 10 maybe it's
five percent maybe it's 15 that's the
job of the agent to go out there and
negotiate but the point is if you're
gonna use my face my body my voice my
everything and I don't get paid for
nothing what the hell am I doing here
you need to pay me fairly that's a very
fair argument in the direction that AI
is going either hire me to do the work
and pay me the full premium 20 million
10 million five million or a hundred
thousand dollars or
if you're going to use my AI my you know
the CGI image you got to still pay me a
certain percentage of it and they can
kind of figure that part out now some
people will say well Pat do you know
what's the average pay actors get paid
in Hollywood according to U.S Bureau of
Labor Statistics they make roughly
27.73 cents per hour some people might
say well you know that's not a lot of
money you should pay me more these
people should get paid more I get it but
27 and 70 that's actually a very good
number minimum wage is 15 bucks if you
want to get paid more like a top gun or
like a Dwayne that guy started off in
his first movie not getting paid that
much money work this web James Franco
and his first movie barely made any
money you can go look at a lot of these
stories of how they got started and they
work their way up you got to do the same
as well if not minimum wage is a pretty
decent minimum wage while the federal
minimum wage is at 720 in California is
that 15 bucks an hour you're 2x
California so that argument let's set
that one aside the next argument is Pat
you know did you know only 12.7 percent
of sag members qualify for unions Health
Plan and a minimum amount of money a
performer must take home in one year to
qualify for health insurance is twenty
six thousand four seventy yeah I get
that you're part-time so that argument
of we should give everybody health
insurance no you you shouldn't because
if somebody's doing second you're doing
one part or one role and you're making
1800 bucks or 1900 you want no that's
not how this works you have to be
full-time committed the tiers need to be
certain higher to be able to offer
health insurance especially knowing how
expensive health insurance is today I
also understand why Bob Iger and the
other guy's gonna be like we're just not
going to do that for you so it is what
it is when it comes down to the health
insurance now the next part is hey look
how much money I'm making or if it's on
network television versus streaming
right I'm not making anything I'm making
pennies on a dollar and a bunch of
people are posting pictures you know
here's one that says you know I made
2.77 for two minutes long and I'm
netting 277. this other person says that
I got one five payments total like 13
cents another person got one that's it
negative one cent another person named
Luke cook on Tick Tock responded saying
I'm only making 7 500 per episode versus
my competitors are getting a hundred
thousand dollars another guy named Jack
bensinger said on seven episodes of TV
residuals he made 19 cents anyways this
keeps going on and on and on all right
valid Network television versus
streaming just everybody knows network
television has gone away so that
business model they were making a lot of
money because they can charge people a
hundred dollars a month for cable two
hundred dollars a month for cable
Netflix is doing 9.99 12.99 the margins
are not the same margins that they have
but on the next round of negotiating
contract get better negotiation on tiers
on what you're going to be doing moving
forward you can't go back and sell what
on anything I've done in my past I want
to be able to do this that negotiation
has already been done unless if it shows
that a renegotiation opportunity is
coming up well then make sure you guys
got the right lawyers defending you this
one 50 50 they can both argue to see
what's going to happen there so remember
when 2007 2008 just the writers went on
a strike and there was a 1.5 billion
dollar discrepancy how much they lost in
La alone remember that whole number we
talked about right now they're
projecting the potential economic impact
impact of the combined writers and
actors strike could cost four billion
dollars or more in damage according to
Kevin cloud and chief Global strategist
for economic think tank at the Milken
Institute he told this to CNN and at the
same time London and UK Australia New
Zealand and other places which either
have Studios or even do post-production
will also face a real impact so then we
start talking about here in St Pat what
do you think about this what do you
think about that and here this person
tweets out saying Disney Won't Give Up
0.091 percent of their revenue to stop
the strike Netflix won't give up 0.214
of the revenue to stop the strike Warner
Brothers Won't Give Up 0.108 percent of
their revenue to stop the strike
Paramount Won't Give Up 0.148 percent of
their revenue to stop the strikes and by
the way this is Petros of Sparta I want
to give them credit these are good
conversations and good debate they don't
have to do it they can still say and say
no problem but why is this important to
you and I so we already know Disney's
gone a completely different direction
and they've lost a lot of families that
no longer trust to put their kids
watching Disney we already know the
direction Netflix is gone with some of
the movies they do with cuties and a lot
of people are like what the hell are you
doing with all these movies why do you
care about my kids so they're already
getting destroyed by the way to give you
a number of what's happened with
revenues over the years okay box office
revenue let me give you this data in
2005 according to statista box office
Global box office revenue in dollars was
23 billion dollars every single year it
went up consecutively till 2019 the year
before covid topping at 42.3 billion
dollars 2020 covet happens it drops to
11.8 billion dollars 2021 21.3 billion
dollars in 2022 it's a little over 25
billion dollars still hasn't gone back
to 42.3 billion dollars in 2019 and now
they're doing strike so guess who gets
affected everybody but more importantly
I sat there and asked a question from
our guys Kelly asked me a question
saying Pat what do you say to this is it
fair what these big companies are doing
these guys are needed they're worried
about what's going to happen with AI and
all this other stuff I said okay great
great let's talk about that yeah radio
is gone nobody listens to radio anymore
what do we do force it to work no it's
podcasts uh what happened to newspapers
newspapers was gone It's All Digital
what happened to all these magazines do
you remember Maxim magazine how big it
was when's the last time you subscribed
to Maxim magazine Flex magazine
bodybuilding gone yeah I can go on
giving you so many different magazines
gone if you don't adapt you're gonna get
destroyed and many people in Hollywood
are getting destroyed because of the
level of innovation that we have however
to give it back to these writers and
sagging actors let me give you my
perspective I sit there I love movies
for me movie is therapy when I ran my
company for many years at the stages
when I was doing 100 hours a week and I
was working Monday through Sunday pretty
much my therapy once a week was when I
needed to go get away from everybody and
turn off my phone as I used to go spend
two hours with 20 80 year olds you know
where at the movie theater hey Patrick
how are you so are we going to watch us
here together I'm like here area I gotta
see some popcorn here's some Icy let's
sit down and I would sit in the back by
myself half the time if the movie was
boring within 15 minutes you know what
I'm doing I'm gone right but it was
therapy because I love movies we went
out the on the most credible website to
see the top 100 greatest movies of all
time if I were to ask you right now
what's the greatest movie of all time
I'm curious what you would say now it's
a tough question I get it give me one of
them we're not on a date I'm just asking
you what's the most incredible movie
you've ever seen in your life some guys
here said you know the Mavericks said
Bambi she said Gladiator Brandon said
different way everybody's giving their
movies right I want you to think about
this watch this do you know out of the
top 100 movies according to IMDb do you
know what decade produced most movies
that aren't the top 100 greatest movies
of all time let's go through it you
ready number one 1950s 20 of them 1970
is second place with 19. third place is
a tie between the 60s and 90s with 15.
next one is 1942 with 12. next one is 19
80s with seven next one 1930s with nine
zero in 2010 the entire decade not one
movie on IMDb is considered a top 100
movie of all time and in the 2000s from
2000 to 2009 it's only three The Pianist
Gladiator and Lord of the Rings why we
have better technology we have better
CGI we have better Photoshop editing
quality stuff that we do how come top
100 movies of all time we haven't had
any pretty much in the last 20 years
even though everything's getting better
because no matter what we do and no
matter how popular porn is nothing
compares to going on a real date no
matter how concerned people are about
you know what's going to happen with
virtual reality there is nothing like
you sitting in front of somebody having
a conversation with them knowing you
need to woo them you need to persuade
them you need to win them over what is
the challenge of me sitting in front of
a virtual reality date where the girl is
fake and she's gonna say everything's
great about me but I know she's lying it
doesn't do anything to me it's the art
of winning that person over the human
being there's something to it go to
Madden Madden if you want to watch a
game the the bodies in Madden game looks
like real football players if you go
watch NBA 2023 the bodies Kobe looks
like Kobe so what happens let's just say
they get it so close to where the bodies
look exactly like exactly where the
players are are you gonna stop watching
the NBA you're just going to go watch
Madden you're just going to go no so CGI
is almost ruining it some of the best
movies were from back in the days I sit
with my my dad and watch his movies I'm
like what this is awesome it's a
beautiful story maybe it's like acting
to have nothing they're just doing it in
a room so I think you and I if you're
American Hollywood storytelling movies
is part of our DNA you guys got to
figure this part out I'm not in the
industry right now you guys got to
figure this part out with the
negotiation and realize I don't care how
great AI is going to be I want to see
the real actor who's got blood who can
get pissed who can screw up and act and
have to do it again I want to see
bloopers I want to see behind the scenes
stuff I want to see the real thing so we
need those guys so no matter how great
AI is going to be I'm not going to sit
there and be like Oh my God look at this
as adults we don't watch a lot of
cartoons we want movies maybe it works
for kids I don't know if it's going to
work for the rest of the guys so closing
thoughts for that industry you guys got
to figure this thing out it's a power
play of course the guys with the money
don't have to do anything the union
people are going to bully quite frankly
when I was selling my company I'll never
forget the guy that was buying my
company he made one of the best things
best phone calls he made to me says
Patrick let me tell you what happens
here he says I'm telling you I'm buying
your company and this is my price and
you've committed to me is it fair I said
I'm all in we're going together he says
the only people that are going to screw
up this deal are going to be lawyers as
long as you and I are on the same page
let's not allow lawyers to ruin this
deal is that a deal one of the most
powerful things he said to me I said
deal you know what happened my lawyers
and his lawyers almost ruined the deal
multiple times and every time remember
what we talked about you're right so
what does this mean hey
Bob Iger heavyweight guys you know who
you are and actors sag writers do not
let junior ruin what you guys have done
the last hundred years that has
entertained people like me and tens if
not billions of people around the world
that don't necessarily like to read
books they get their education sometimes
from movies they don't like docs they
like movies don't let the union screw up
the amazing work you've done in the past
and if I can whisper one other thing to
you leave our kids alone just make some
movies like the movies that we want to
see don't do all the other ESG
stuff that you're getting involved in
and this Larry finkai is now controlling
you guys don't get involved in that
it makes us sick if you go that
route you are not going to get this
guy's a customer but if you say hey yes
you think we don't need your money not
not you not Vanguard not State Street
we're going to kind of figure out a way
to do it ourselves and we're going to be
very cool with the way we're making our
movies going back to the days we did it
when we built all these top 100 greatest
movies of all time great and if we do
that maybe this decade 2020 to 2020 nine
maybe we can produce a couple movies
that will be on that list of top 100
greatest movies of all time what do you
think about that and by the way if you
got value out of this episode give it a
thumbs up subscribe to the channel more
importantly I did a video about the
history of Hollywood for some of you
that forgot about it maybe you ought to
look at it and see why you escaped New
Jersey and you were under the control of
a guy named Thomas Edison and you're
doing it again don't repeat that same
mistake if you haven't seen that video
click here or here to watch that video
take care everybody bye bye
foreign